these days the world is full of
different takes on the news
we get reporters takes and pundits takes
and politicians takes
and random people on social media's
takes but there's one important take
that's missing
your mom's take so we'd like to bring
that to you now in a segment called
your mom's take
[Music]
that's right we brought your mom to our
studio
hi there don't slouch
yes ma'am so i'm gonna read some recent
headlines and after each one
your mama's gonna give us her take on it
you're welcome
all right here we go u.s men failed to
qualify for olympic soccer tournament
well they tried their best and that's
what matters
good job that's that should have said
good job
yeah i agree they tried they tried they
tried their best
woman gives birth to nine babies at once
i bet none of them are as handsome as
you
oh okay mom
caitlyn jenner announce his run for
california governor
you can't trust a 71 year old caitlyn
caitlin should be 30 years old most
uh here's what women want in a man
laryngitis
you think you get your sense of humor
from your father but you get it from me
that's true also my sense of rhythm why
ellen degeneres is living with courtney
cox
it's probably the same reason your aunt
brenda is living with her roommate
[Music]
okay for five hundred dollars bon jovi
will wish your mom a happy mother's day
why are you too good to do it yourself
no no
my happy mother's day that's right
that's what
i thought the most
promising coronavirus vaccine you've
never heard of it's called
a good attitude mom a good attitude
won't prevent coving
you wouldn't know you don't have one
good one and finally
bill gates announces divorce from
melinda gates
mom what are you doing i'm making a
dating profile
you're married to dad i could get a bill
gates
i mean i still have it yes you do mom
and this has been your mom's take
now when are you going to get married oh
my grandchildren
um i'll have new children with bill
gates
smart children okay mom smart little
inventor yeah they will be they are
smart
inventor children mm-hmm i will not have
to save up for them to go to college
mom i got a scholarship i got a
scholarship to go to school
mm-hmm i played football oh you did your
best
oh
[Music]
you